[Music]
you're doing stand-up I'm doing stand-up
again and I've been running around with
her man
Schneider and norm and Tim Meadows and
Swardson and yet we've been running
around yeah I remember years and years
and years ago I got the late-night show
this is 1993 no one knows who I am and
I'm haven't even premiered yet and you
said Cohn and beyond my comedy album oh
yeah
and you and I was like oh I guess so but
no one knows who I am II went oh it's
gonna be great and it was the filthiest
that I did on yeah you were the buffoon
I was and Coney just got your I just got
my own show and I know you know we love
Cohn and he thought he was the funniest
guy and I wanted you to be on my album
before that just so you know yeah
before you were a superstar but but
anyways I had no idea that it would be
bad for ya all right
filthy filthy filthiest kid and I handed
him the stuff and and sweet going he's
looking at it like is there any change
but we did it you were very nice to me
you committed to it and NBC dealt with
it like pants yeah they did they got
their revenge they waited 16
you